yes I do think that the black matters
course a stick a new urgency in this
current climate if we think for example
of the the most recent elections right
the campaign's that we that we we all
heard on TV on the radio in the
newspapers it's clear that identity
politics little bit a key role so if you
think of the various claims about
immigrants about Muslims about race
about blacks identity politics I think
was was a major focus of the campaign
and I think the students themselves when
I look at so I when we started I gave
out the questionnaires asking them why
they took the course what drove them to
black matters in many of them actually
assume that the course is called black
matters because of the black lives
matter movement but in fact that course
started ten years ago before there was a
black lives matter movement
but listen themselves they came to the
course wanting to address current fiscal
issues including issues of of race of
identity of migration of religious
hatred so I definitely there was a sense
of urgency coming especially from from
the students perspective themselves they
wanted to discuss these issues and get a
better understanding of how to process
but also how to counter some of these
claims about identity race religion
migration etcetera so so as I was
thinking about the syllabus and the
course description I couldn't help but
but thinking about the slogan of
building walls to protect say the US and
as I was picking text and choosing guest
speakers like that it was important to
create a new narrative around this issue
of walls because I think that our
humanity is enriched when we can build
bridges instead of breaking walls so so
for me in the course and also for some
of my guest speakers it was important to
create a new narrative around the
concept of building bridges that indeed
will make this world great not just the
US but the world great